hey youtubers it's Charlie doctor who is
back into the fire so careful for
spoilers from episode 1 if you haven't
seen it yet how about that tease at the
end everybody start growing their master
Roger Delgado beard out I love the way
that they're bringing back the Johnson
master while we also have Missy meaning
we might get a master team-up like what
is he doing here if she's already here
there's so much to explain it's a lot
like a doctor running into other
versions of himself like it just gets
extra crazy it probably has something to
do with the mysterious looking vault
beneath the school that the doctor is
trying to hide oh good he doesn't want
the vault it's just chasing us it wants
to kill us like he was so happy it's the
monster in this episode didn't want
anything to do with what he was trying
to protect so that is just a giant hat
tip to it being this huge MacGuffin for
the rest of the series they might reveal
it in the next episode we might wait
till the end of the series before we
actually find out what's inside they're
very reminiscent of the Pandorica just
this mysterious box you wonder what the
mystery is that's inside so what we'll
do is like a top five then I'll talk
about Easter eggs and address like all
the big WTF moments at the end of the
episode particularly the John Simm
return but overall I felt like it was a
great starter for the series they
usually try to make episodes like this
jumping on points for new audience
members clearly they've aged it down
just a little bit even though the
spin-off series class is about a bunch
of actual school kids so this is still
like a little bit older but the doctor
is an actual professor which is
metaphorically what he's been since
Capaldi's taken over but now they're
making it a literal thing in number five
meet bill the apt pupil who just opened
to learning whatever it like she has
these crazy ideas in her head maybe
they're lizards possessing her brain so
it's their way of letting you know that
she just opened to the really wild
concepts that she'll be introduced to as
the doctor tutors her across space and
time so I love pearl Mackey's energy she
actually said that before she got the
role she'd only watched like one episode
of Doctor Who but I don't think that's
necessary for being a good actor like
Doctor Who is one of those things where
you have to reference all the stuff
that's come before like inside the
doctor's office you have the pictures of
River Song Susan you have all these
things around him that are easter eggs
for the stuff that's come before the
other adventures that he's been on but
you need to move forward so Bill's going
to be a really fun way to do that where
have to explain things to her so like
she's the audience surrogate where
people who never watch Doctor Who before
get to learn about new concepts like
what's a Dalek well a Dalek is just a
Dalek come on let's go so I love the
introduction and I love the setting to
the University they say you've been
teaching here for 70 plus years they're
basically just talking about the entire
life of the Doctor Who series ever since
the pilot episode this episode was
called the pilot so it referenced a lot
of things that happened during the 2005
pilot episode the reboot series pilot in
the original episode of Doctor Who when
the series was conceived he was an old
professor teaching young students taking
them through adventures teaching them
about history literally in the episode
though the pilot was the thing that the
water creature took over it was like a
sentient water based spaceship that
needed a human host to serve as its
pilot that was the girl that bill fell
in love with it was looking for a
partner to travel with it in the way the
doctor was looking for a partner to
travel with him on the TARDIS so there
were a lot of parallels between bill and
the doctor in this water creature and
bill and I loved the lecture that the
doctor gives at the top of the episode
where he talks about what would happen
if all of your life was laid out in
front of you would it be like a city
later in the episode when bill touched
the creature it sort of did that for her
he showed her her entire life all of
time and space collapsed into that
single moment so they were literally
showing you time and relative dimension
in space the way the doctor was talking
about it at the beginning of the episode
so doctor who was always amazing with
visual metaphors number three though the
doctor destroys or gets rid of the water
monster by taking it to the mobile and
Dalek war if you didn't recognize it
this is the fourth doctor's sonic
screwdriver
the reason they probably picked this one
of all the ones like they have the jar
with every single sonic screwdriver ever
earlier in the episode sitting on his
desk so the reason they probably pick
this one during this part of the episode
is because a lot of the mobile and stuff
the doctor who has done overlap with
Davros stories that is a lot of fourth
fifth doctor adventures so that's
probably why they take this one but I
love the way that he brings the water
creatures there because the deadliest
fire in the universe is there and that
is the Daleks but the Dalek blast
does not faze it at all a minute later
eats the Dalek implying that it's this
crazy powerful creature but it has the
same powers as the TARDIS so of course
there's no way to kill it bill has to
let it go to find some other solution so
the metaphor here though is that it's a
bit of a hat tip for what's probably
happening with the master this season
someone who is too powerful for the
doctors who ever get rid of completely
his greatest enemy and his greatest
friend so there was this really cool
speech that the doctor had about evil in
the episode and I also think that's more
of a hat tip for the master later this
season as well - both versions of the
master in that he says things are very
rarely evil in the universe most things
are just hungry and hunger is often
confused for evil so the water creature
was just hungry for a companion the way
the doctor himself is hungry for a
companion in the master is hungry for
the doctors companionship so the
fundamental truth that they're putting
forward in this episode is that
everybody in the universe just wants
somebody else
that wants them so does that not sound
like Missy and the doctor and the master
and the doctor although for the most
part it's been this weird relationship
because Missy has been a female version
of the master so there's always been
this subtle sexual layer to it but we
have the male version of the John Simm
master back looking kind of like a
classic Roger Delgado version so before
we get ahead of ourselves let's see how
number two the big tease at the
you're the one can you freight that
array
the Delta I've been standing by the
gates of your world to be you all safe
I'm not stopping now
any questions the Mondas Cybermen
returned the doctors regeneration in
fact that's probably the biggest WTF the
doctor regenerating before the end of
the series they did say that they had
already filmed the doctors final
regeneration but they have not filmed
the Christmas special which Capaldi will
be doing so because this is his final
season presumably we'll meet the new
doctor during the Christmas special they
haven't confirmed that yet they could
wait to the beginning of series 11 but
if you remember when Matt Smith
regenerated it was during his last
Christmas special that was the first
time we saw the Capaldi doctor so they
might do the same thing with Capaldi but
they just haven't released a whole bunch
of that information yet but the cool
thing is is they're bringing back a host
of classic villains and updating them so
like the Ice Warriors are featured
heavily during that teaser they're
beefing them up big time so they're
refreshing the series itself visually
creatively and the refreshing a lot of
the concepts but I really like the way
the doctor gave her that final speech to
like you know all these really big
sci-fi concepts but it all came from
this very emotional core this hunger for
something more so bill is hungry for
more the doctor is going to give that to
her this season with a bunch of crazy
adventures but of course you know number
one WTF is John Simm returning big twist
there have been a couple of stories in
the past where there have been multiple
masters featured but most of them have
been either the comics or the novels
there's the eight doctors the five
masters the harvest of time in the two
masters which is an audio story so the
big twist here is the last time we saw
the John Simm version of the master is
he was attacking Rassilon with his life
force during the end of time but then
when we got to the 50th anniversary
there was the revelation that all 13
doctors were helping save Gallifrey from
the Dalek war in the pocket universe
then later during the series 9 finale we
saw Rassilon again meaning that if he
survived then the master somehow
survived but we saw Missy so at some
point we'll have to explain what
happened to the master after this
instant right here in how he became
Missy when that regeneration took place
presumably
with him back they'll explain that but
all we know right now is that it looks
like the master is traveling along his
own timeline the way that the doctor has
done before like the 50th anniversary
where there's different doctors from
different eras interacting with each
other on screen so the only other thing
that we know about this shot is that it
looks like he's looking at bill because
you kind of see her poofy hair sticking
over the top of the frame here but
that's all the context we have so let me
know what did you guys think about the
episode and what are all your Johnson
master theories so what can happen is is
I'm not planning on doing weekly episode
videos but I will do videos for big
reveals like when Johnson actually comes
on I'll definitely do a video for that
I'll do explainers for big concepts if
you guys want so just leave all your
doctor who' requests in the comments
below but while you wait for my next
video you can click here to catch up on
all the Star Wars trailers and clips
that I've been posting this weekend and
you can click here for brand-new Game of
Thrones thank you so much for watching
let's high five you guys the next video
[Music]